In today's video, we are taking
an ultrasonic vaporizer,
seeing if we can make
a colored mist,
and if we can,
what we can do with it.
[Music]
Guys, this is
an ultrasonic vaporizer.
It's the component
that's normally found inside of
a humidifier to make the mist.
It makes the vapor
that comes out of a humidifier.
In this container here,
we've got a big fancy one.
It's basically 12
of these little ones all wired
up together in one housing.
So ultrasonic vaporizers
are meant to be used with water,
and they make a super
fine opaque vapor.
We want to see
what we can do with it.
Here's the basic idea.
Using a component commonly found
in household humidifiers,
we're going to try
to make colored fog
out of food coloring.
We're going to do a quick test,
first, with our little
single plate vaporizer.
We're going to plug
this thing in,
and we're going to watch
how it works.
We're using a clear cup
so you should at least
be able to see some of it.
However, our vision
might get a little obscured
as it does fill
with vapor pretty quickly.
So we can see the ultrasonic
vaporizer down here,
and then we've got
a lot of clear water
where you can see little bits
of stuff floating around,
and that it's not still water.
But it doesn't really look
like it's doing too much.
Up here at the top however,
you can see water
is just being shot out,
and drips all over,
and that's why we're doing
this on top of a towel.
So, the ultrasonic humidifier
actually uses ultrasonic waves,
and it creates sort of fine mist
through the water itself
with a broken capillary wave
at the water's surface.
[Music]
The vaporizer has
a ceramic plate
that's oscillating several
thousand times per second.
The way that impacts
the water forces
it to break up into
microscopically small droplets,
which form a fog.
When this is in a humidifier,
those microscopic droplets
quickly evaporate into the air,
adding humidity and moisture.
That's our small-scale one.
Now, we're going to try
the large-scale one.
Like I said,
this has 12 of those,
and this is probably a much
higher quality brand.
The small one is
from Amazon and cost $10,
and while it's very cool,
it's not exactly the most
stable, well-built thing.
They can only be on
for a few hours
before they break.
So, you need to limit
how long you leave
them on a time.
This one is designed
to be a lot more sturdy,
and obviously, it's bigger.
This one's actually one
that's made for a pond,
so it's made for a much
larger surface of water.
Yay.
Again, there's a reason
we have the towel down.
This is just shooting a lot
of water up and out
of the container,
but you can see this
is also making a lot of vapor.
[Music]
Something interesting
about this mist is even
though it's been
running for a while,
and we have quite
a good fog down in the jar,
it's not really escaping
the jar very much
unless I blow down into it.
The mist that this
makes is really dense,
and this is designed,
as Calli said,
to go in a pond
or a lake or something,
and flow over the
whole surface of it.
When it's in the jar,
it just can't build up enough
that it escapes out
the top very well.
So I have here a bike pump
that I've modified a little bit,
and by modifying,
I mean, I tore
the front out of it.
He means a lot.
Usually, it has like
a valve built out of that.
So if you are pumping
air into something,
it doesn't pump
it right back out.
We didn't want that.
We just wanted physically
a giant syringe.
So now, we can just put the bike
pump down in there, pull back,
and it's full
of our water vapor,
and there's something I
definitely want to try.
I want to see
if we can use this
to blow bubbles.
Shall we try this?
I'm always having fun.
I know.
Yes, it works.
Nice.
And they're kind of sticking.
So we were taking
our little pump syringe, and we
were filling it with vapor,
and they were blowing it
through the bubble wand.
Now, we've decided
to cut out a step,
and we're just dipping
the front of our syringe
into the bubble soap,
and we're just making
the bubble directly on it.
That was a really
good vapor bubble.
[Music]
All right, so here's
the next thing we want to try.
We've got a bunch
of food coloring,
and we want to see
if we can actually change
the color of the vapor itself.
Now, the vapor were looking at,
it looks white.
It comes across as
being a white vapor,
but in truth,
this vapor is clear.
These are tiny tiny droplets
of clear water.
It looks white
because we're shining
white light on it,
and that's getting
reflected around.
A lot of the time,
with things like bubbles
or vapor, mist,
stuff like that,
it's really hard
to change the color of it
because it's actually just
such a very very thin amount
that it's just clear
and reflects whatever
light is around it.
But we're going to try.
We've got a lot
of food coloring,
and we might be able
to make this work.
All right, we're going to start
with blue food coloring,
and we're going to use
a ton of it to see
if we can get this to work.
I think we should try
an entire bottle of blue,
and there's only about
a cup of water in here,
probably less with
the vaporizer there.
So that's pretty concentrated.
Yep.
An entire bottle?
Whole thing.
All right.
[Music]
Look at how it's
like sinking down.
That's cool.
All right.
This is intense.
Here it goes.
[Music]
So what do you think?
Is that actually blue vapor?
You know, I wish
I could say yes,
but I don't think so.
So there are some types
of like essential oils,
even that are made
specifically to dissolve
sort of into the surface
of the water in a humidifier.
But even then,
it's not necessarily
part of the vapor.
It's just getting
picked up with it.
I don't think that's
what's happening here.
I think that's
still a white vapor.
I'm--
So I'm trying to like pointed
at the side to keep it
from splashing out,
>> and I'm not--
>> There is the color.
I mean the splash is
not really part of--
Yeah, we're really just
getting a white fog here.
Guys, we did one.
We're going to add four more.
[Music]
There's such a delayed reaction.
Wait!
Wait.
That actually looks like
>> it's colored.
>> That might be blue?
[Music]
It's so--
>> I think--
>> It's very subtle,
but I'm pretty sure
we've got blue right there.
I'm also curious,
this is water vapor.
If you blow it out
directly onto the paper,
will the paper like pick it up?
Look at that.
It's like the
worst airbrush ever.
Don't move.
[Music]
We are out of blue.
We're not out of
the other colors.
And we have a lot of this one.
We do.
We do have black.
So here's the next thought.
We added a lot of food coloring
to a little bit of water,
but what if we try a lot
of food coloring and no water?
There's none.
Straight food coloring.
Let's do it.
[Music]
Moment of truth.
Pure green food coloring.
Wow, you can see it already.
It does not produce
nearly as much vapor.
But what vapor it
is producing is very colorful.
I wonder if we added
just a little bit
of water to raise the height.
[Music]
That's my new favorite.
That's got color.
[Music]
So there's like white
vapor at the top,
and greener vapor at the bottom.
I think.
It could just be
the green food coloring,
but I'm going to pop it,
and we can see
if the vapor looks green.
There's still--
That's green vapor.
There's still green vapor
in there for sure.
That's so cool.
[Music]
Why do they--
Okay, whatever is
in food coloring should
be used to make bubbles.
We had the best result,
like the most intense color
by using pure food coloring.
We have five bottles of the red.
I don't know
if that's enough to fully
cover our ultrasonic vaporizer.
I don't think so
but we should try.
So, we'll see what we can do.
Here goes red.
Switch on in 3, 2, 1.
[Music]
It's kind of got like a bloody
mist thing happening here.
[Music]
All right, I'm going for it.
It's definitely
making vapor now.
Yeah.
And it has color.
There's almost no vapor
coming off of this.
[Music]
Oh, wait.
Almost.
A little.
It's not as powerful
as the green.
[Music]
You had it for like
a small second.
And I have paid the price.
Oh, no.
This is what happens
if you make food
color bubbles, kids.
Bubbles full of colored vapor.
It is possible.
Colored vapor is
possible to make.
Yeah.
I never would have thought that.
That is pretty gnarly.
I'm going to be
wearing it forever.
But I love it.
Guys, we are going
to start releasing exclusive
t-shirt designs every month
that are only available
for that month.
The design this month
is this one.
So click the link in
the description now to get yours
before they're gone forever.
Guys, you know the drill.
That's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
The box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you're ever gonna miss
out on the full video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
so you get notified about it.
We'll see you the next one.
Talk to you then.